the Shroud of Turin the burial cloth of  the Prophet Jesus has been taken from  its safekeeping authorities are pointing  to Giovanna no Sarah her network is  known to reach well beyond Europe I'd  like you're ready to call the return you  said that not me  they're gonna take DNA from the blood of  the Shroud of Turin the package is very  delicate  just stick to procedures you know we  gonna find ya okay okay  I was the anchorman for the local news  we have information links you to a chain  that may be transporting illegal  materials everything just crumbled I  not something's on its way straighten  out this damn mess  you think Christ is coming he's supposed  to come again I'm calling rose oh you  wish to God it didn't happen but it did  time changes every second and so do we  you don't get it  it's  they call that Karma  what do you know about call not much but  I'm learning